Hello and welcome to the second part of our software engineering course. In the
previous mini-course, we discussed some basic principles
behind software engineering. We provided an overview of
several software process models and we introduced
some important tools that can help developers
increase their productivity. In this mini-course, we
will focus on requirement and prototyping. More precisely,
we will discuss in depth requirements
engineering activities. We will also discuss
techniques to perform a system analysis
and design in an object-oriented fashion. So,
let's start the first lesson of this mini-course, which is about the use
of engineering techniques to understand and
specify the purpose of a software system.